I want to talk to you guys about
previous winners of game of the year
here at gamespot com but actually before
that 2014 in video games bit of a
strange year kind of a large breadth of
games lots of good games across a bunch
of different platforms and do you think
it was when we looked at sort of the
list of games that came out last year
there were so many like absolute gems
this year there seems to be like just a
way smaller how it's the difference
between the final year for a set of old
platforms in the first full year for
some new platforms but I think you know
a lot of developers you get the
impression they were caught a little
flat-footed by the release so yeah a lot
of ports a lot of broken game yeah so
many lot broken dreams up it's been a
real weird year did you guys have
trouble picking your a game of the year
oh we always do you know so we were
always you know deliberate in grand
fashion yell at each other all that sort
of stuff but we we did manage to get it
done and we did just the bed as well and
we're going to get to once we unveil the
winner later in the show we're going to
have a little powwow between some of the
folks that are involved in those
deliberations and take questions from
you folks as well watching about some of
the other games that might have won if
they just done that a little bit extra
but first of all I have in front of me a
list a dubious list some wonderful games
some some questionable winners of the
past fashionable winner I'm not saying
there's interesting career games that
like maybe at the time seemed like the
best game but then once years past
sometimes series get more popular
sometimes other ones fade into sort of
nothingness you forget about it's it's
it's the thing that long-running
publications get to do where the new
staff gets to come in and then I wrap
all over what the people did in the past
the source did it they reviewed a bunch
of rap albums it like this is this is a
classic I really yeah 20 years later
obviously you can look back and say yeah
that's a classic way to make these
decisions in heat of the moment I guess
you were in 1996 yeah you were maybe not
on a PC side right you're working at
gamespot yeah yeah we were working on we
launched a video game spot calm hmm
check it out very hot side um we
launched that in October or add it was a
December first 96 so we lost it a little
later on for December we had watched
with 100 reviews which I
I wrote too many of those mmm very late
at night anyway we did we were too busy
getting the site launched I think to
pick a game of the year that year okay
and I don't even know if we did one in
97 or not it's all a blur at this point
but the pc side did and they picked at
diablo again i'm sure is that diablo
diablo is love it's Diab it's Diablo
okay unless you're yeah unless you're
Randy Pitchford I've heard him say die a
blow at all the times that's a that's a
pretty tight winner I've gotta power
through some of these because I want to
get into discussions about someone a
more recent ones and 97 a total
annihilation one yeah since pretty
Haysom a very reasonable again was there
a second one let's just say that ta is
the game okay anything that you may have
heard it like has just ignore that sort
of stuff they were putting out units on
like cover discs for magazines oh really
it was nonsense at 98 of course a
classic year in gaming an ocarina of
time one that was also the year that
grim fandango came out and half-life 1
did Mellish solid command 98 as well
yeah 98 was one of the best years for
games starcraft we have to remember that
was a year that they split it there were
actually two games of the years there
was a grim grim fandango one on pc um
and then of course Ocarina of Time want
a video game so is that we were yeah we
were to split sites there was no real
shared editorial yeah I never reported
into someone who was on the pc side at
that time but generally speaking like we
kind of we made our own decisions and
didn't have to worry about what all the
pc weirdos were into that here how many
folks were involved in those
Liberation's and for your side uh you
know i'm trying to think like the year
that ocarina came out like our
deliberations would have maybe been five
people six people something like that
you know Joe fielder robbe donald myself
more humble doon might have been there
that by anyway yeah was it was ocarina
the first ten out of ten yeah as well
yeah i think the second tenet of ten was
in 1999's winner on for the console soft
which was soul calibur yes soul calibur
also got a 10 and the winner for that on
pc was EverQuest I don't remember eq
having that long of a lifespan after
that is that just because we now live in
a post world of warcraft world with 10
years of status
okay maybe I'm showing my age at this
day they're still doing expansions for
that damn thing ever seen yet request
neck silly does relax yeah oh yeah but
old stuff yeah I want to talk about the
year two thousand folks the winner on
for consoles chrono cross that game got
a 10 and thus had to be game of the year
because what we would we be doing if we
didn't Jesus did we really give it a
crime yeah yeah by that why that am like
you and I have had a conversation yes
this set about Chrono Cross and the way
it got a 10 yeah um so I need to fit on
this all over this one add the pc game
oh the sims 1 on pc beating ash at deus
ex on diablo 2 diablo 2 I would have
taken either of those two game over the
sims yeah Sims was like a I did Polly a
Dave Ivanovich I yeah anybody I had like
super important 25 expansion packs as
well or maybe maybe more actually
[ __ ] once at least sims 1 yes the
first Mike I know 24 1189 and it was
recognized as such in his year of
release by a crack shot staff that knew
exactly no a 2001 at Grand Theft Auto 3
better of games like halo smash bros and
i'm not sure if max payne actually came
out on consoles that year i think it
came a baby here later yeah and but yeah
I'm in serious on the first encounter
when I'm pc i love that there's a
certain you know there's a certain type
of game that I think resonated with the
pc side of GameSpot at that time ya know
as the sites merged I think you saw that
attitude kind of cross both sides but
there was a certain appreciation were
just like games that got it done okay
there were just extremely focused and
just nailed that thing particularly
well-liked serious sam was like like
took if i remember correctly like it
took that staff by storm like they
couldn't stop talking about serious sam
I kind of played it when like yeah this
is cool it kind of was that because like
crow team were such an unknown at that
is due for like the old thing it was
like a return to you know it's like
think about where first-person shooters
got at that point everything gotten so
complicated like it was a return to form
of just like screw it we're gonna just
shoot stuff and have a great time
just headless thing screams at you all
again zat you like there's a lot less
efficient legs and then crow team just
got nine out of 10 on the side for the
Talos yeah could I thought that
particular developer would have made
that gay know where I'm 2002 Metroid
Prime on gamecube I don't think you
gonna have many people disagreeing with
that one yeah yeah just me you're gonna
discreet that yeah what I couldn't tell
you what I would choose over it not a
fan of my just never never was a fan of
the Chris you know from with you Jeff I
mean it's didn't I don't know didn't my
child like the first person shooters
yeah I Metroid Prime it up like it never
struck me as a great first person
shooter it was an interesting and really
cool way to realize Metroid in a
first-person format but I just never
connected with any of those games the
same I connected with a side-scrolling
Metroid game and second Zelda on the
list 2003 Wind Waker that's kind of an
interesting one because i really like
winwaker but then it was like the first
Zelda I played nothing in twitter is
amazing like okay forget the back third
where you gotta go over the place get
the pieces of the map and you know all
that sort of stuff but winwaker is
incredible like it looked amazing like
that to me seemed like an easy choice uh
just like looking back on it now I
couldn't tell you what it was up against
cuz you know beautiful Joe beautiful Joe
is that beautiful Joe star wars the old
republic a knights of the old republic
pardon i need to make sure i might i
think i'd take a zelda / beautiful Josie
honest be Nigel's yeah beautiful Joe was
a neat idea winwaker is a fully-realized
amazing thing at 2000 for another
fantastic year in video games and that
immediately springs to mind half-life 2
for me but I gotta say I think they've
got this one right world of warcraft
best game you can't really argue without
the game still exists today that was
actually one of the stiffest arguments
we had for a game of the year really
because world of warcraft was so popular
that it pulled in the entire console
side of the staff who were playing world
of warcraft and then fighting very hard
for it so you had stalwarts on the pc
side they're like you're only saying
that because it's the first one of these
you play right okay it's weird so the pc
cred Roxy fighting against the prize
just enter park okay actually but she
got two point real like dude like stop
like everyone
this game this game is fantastic like
just stop surely okay Kosovan was in the
world of warcraft I believe he he
reviewed that game he did a fantastic
him like we've a the smartest thing
Blizzard ever did was give copious
amounts of beta access to as many people
on staff as possible because they led to
and that's the smartest thing I think a
lot of MMO developers could do is just
like just get the game out there to
people because it's like people are
gonna need to play it and they did that
and everyone played it everyone got
weird hooked on it um and yeah that's
that's what it have that happening I
remember being extra sort of frothing at
the mat in Europe because of course we
didn't get that game until I think it
was maybe last week in January first
week of februari and the next year so it
was even more anticipation 2005 and
second game cube sorry third GameCube
game that's crazy three to four years
and resident evil 4 man best Resident
Evil game ever made I would say it's the
best Resident Evil game for media that
was one of the glazed look up a lot of
the games for me that just absorbed all
my thoughts when I was not playing it
and I just kept wanting to go back and
play it all the time never liked the
shooting never liked resident evil to
begin with those really sort of you know
like that whole game was just lost on me
I was just like yeah it's really
beautiful I understand why people liked
it but I couldn't stand up for me that
was the reason that was the last one
that sort of got me to get a gamecube
and then there was like a bunch of extra
fantastic like half a dozen other games
are kind of most plays at that stage a
2006 Chris when did you come on stuff I
joined the staff in 2007 but it was
until eight that I was doing reviews at
Gears of War for xbox 360 2006 and this
was my first year at games Oh real
though I wasn't in those discussions for
the most part Abbott Jack years I feel
like that was that was awesome event
game everyone was playing is uh yeah it
really was like that game really did
stand out at the time you know it didn't
necessarily invent the cover shooter you
know it games a kill switch before yeah
kind of doing similar stuff obviously
wreck of Resident Evil you know for kind
of had some of the mechanics that we
would go on to see in years I just think
they they honed that game so well at
that point that you know between active
reload just like tons of smart stuff
across the board with that thing and
that extra kick of it being the HD right
so yeah yeah moving up a console that
the game was incredibly impressive at
the time in fact it's funny now because
we've obviously pulled footage for this
as well
whenever I've ever looked for footage of
gears of war it's looks like absolute
janky because we're so used to have
three look in the exact same perspective
same character one looks like a mess
yeah it looks like a kid today yeah
other games that year were oblivion dead
rising and viva pinata viva pinata
should have one there I totally agree i
was my that was a lot that was actually
my number of my personal number 142
thousands for both of you I didn't think
you'd take the bait that here at 2007 as
super mario galaxy on the wii bed at
games like halo modern warfare bioshock
and crisis i made good year I made it up
to November of that year okay well and
then did not said you know I I'm just
taking a little bit of a break okay why
he didn't get into the mini stick around
for the meetings for that one would you
pick galaxy [ __ ] no you know like modern
no that was the year that modern warfare
came yeah close did you know like halo 3
was a fantastic game at that point to
like you know I'd yeah would you've gone
modern warfare over halo 3 yes you you
might have been able to like tip the
scales too because that was the discuss
that was what the discussion came down
to its mean was basically modern warfare
vs super mario galaxy Wow well the
deliberations were always were never
about like being fair or voting or
anything that it literally was who could
talk to loudest no really um I got
pretty good at that over the years I'm
just being just you just kind of end up
forcing your will shoot on people until
they just go fine like the bart last
parts leaving in five minutes of there
okay that's here that's why i drove at
don Rikard i can hear him screaming in
the background already 2008 metal gear
solid four sons of the patriots on
playstation tree you reviewed that i did
actually that that year actually did
come down to the two tens um grand theft
auto four metal gear solid four oh yeah
we went with metal gear solid that was a
contentious year though i was i remember
the kind of like projecting your
presence being part of what you were
saying yeah totally like this very much
of this like a just get out there yeah
stick your chest out and hope for the
best so GTA was reviewed by justin
cousin calvert yeah and and ultimately
it's funny because Justin was the one
arguing he argued against GTA oh and on
behalf of metal gear solid 4 which he
liked more and but GTA 4 is another
problem
discussion for another time in general
yep that game people look back on that
with disdain yes in a way like fantastic
yeah the climate was like it I really
really love that game um you know
whether it held up or not like you know
that's the debate but i want to say we
went with a GTA that year at join bomb
but again it's all a blur yes I I adored
that game i thought the online in that
as well it was kind of reminiscent the
Gears of War days where everyone seemed
to be playing it was like super
interesting good yeah I think that that
was the Irwin GTA when the story in
action sorted seems to be at odds with
each other we're like the story of this
one character was supposed to be I just
want to get it they just got so good at
telling their stories and a lot of the
stuff that I think it's workout
disjointed but they tried to ground the
game I mean you think about them coming
off of San Andreas and what's andreas
was like it was smart for them to go
like all right new generation consoles
who made our table tennis let's get back
to the the roots reality hitting a ball
one another and then also going out on
dates or whatever but uh yeah and not
jet packs and all that yeah weird ms in
like there's I could tell he was like
the tony hawk underground of basically
today so I can stick her slapping away
that was the first time we're hearing
the term Ludo narrative dissonance of
the gta4 that's the first time I'm
afraid that's the first time I ever
remember that turns the monster from a
coming up okay exactly yeah exactly
that's it that's a cultural touchstone
all of our viewers can get behind we
have a 2009 demon souls on playstation 3
did you review thought I did um I
actually think that's one of the best
things we ever did not that year was
uncharted two and assassin's creed 2 and
modern warfare and modern warfare yeah a
lot of rhythm I actually think that was
a really great choice oh it was also a
indistinct you were voting for best game
of the year but this a most game of the
year alright but this was this this was
a pretty easy thing to come it actually
came down to assassin's creed 2 and this
I think yeah and a c2 is probably the
best a sausage great game it is of the
boy usually surely yeah the best
assassin looking about Brotherhood uh
yeah but that's like assassin's creed
two extra yeah it's like they just
changed it and made it
yeah if you want a reward ac2 for being
first venture I'm just a block of black
on that on that video review what the
hell that's what happens we're showing
Karina's shirt in this that was all shot
on this gigantic massive ridiculous
green screen really said well yeah like
let's make it look real and good because
it's the internet people want stuff that
looks like television this green screen
we have here is so much better I know
yeah this is Greta this is just like
this is top-notch stuff to be fair with
all that Menace though good you stay
there are green all green screen better
than fan menace so we got that going
other stories at 2010 red dead
redemption thanks I came in pretty great
like sure I feel like that's a real easy
one yeah that was a pretty smooth year I
think what else came out thank you cod
blops mass effect 2 starcraft 2 and
Galaxy 2 which we actually gave you 10
alone let me tell you about a little
game called mass effect 2 the best my
last mass effect yeah true only by
virtue of three being such a
disappointment surely describing such a
disappointment we feel it would have
been great if mass effect 3 had been
better than aspect too yeah the same way
to was better than one yeah but the
story the elements the stuff they nailed
Adam aspect to mass effect 2 sounds a
lot like a game that I would give game
of the year too especially was this
other stuff did you give it that sounds
right dad's is not that God come on well
you know what my person was vanquished
for that year so i don't know what i'm
talking about me she was good but give
it a game video they stopped crazy
person like if you're giving like an
individual top 10 list then yeah I cool
like it was but vanquish on it but
missing a staff of people to agree on a
game and the other thing is like you can
convince everyone to just agree with it
yeah so it's no one's favorite things
you say that it's everyone's like number
two or number three they got like I can
live with that yeah I'm never gonna get
vanquish up at 2011 this is my first
year here and I remember coming down to
either portal 2 or Skyrim and there was
a bunch of us in the UK huddled around a
phone and we eventually just went to a
vote and portal T was winning by 2 I
think and then all four of us voted for
Skyrim in Skyrim ended up being the
winner scar was pretty great game that's
that's manifesting the games by UK is
everybody
the best RPG that year it was the third
best RPG that year compared to what what
what Dark Souls which or two namitha on
those are action-adventure games
uncharted 3 came in not here as well so
sir uncharted 3 sucked Arkham City came
at that year's well drawn words what
time we should win just saying
alternatives I gotta say though Arkham
City and portal 2 like they came on the
same year and those are two games that i
would consider in terms of like what
they actually did how they delivered on
it as close to perfect in that kind of
execution way as I think games can kind
of get what one is better than portal 2
I don't know what you think but that's a
discussion it's yeah but that is the
same as the assassins grants you
argument where it did it first and it
was far more impressive like when you
like playing through the original portal
like I felt smart every time I finished
a puzzle I was right oh this is great
portal to a lot of the puzzle design
made me feel like I was an idiot when I
was solving the puzzles it was like oh
what the hell like oh I guess that's
what I'm supposed to do like I just feel
like it was not as tight or as good as
the first game we're catching up on 2014
2012 dear mass effect 3 far cry 3 x com
Assassin's Creed 3 Borderlands 2 walking
dead max payne 3 and Halo 4 K marriage
we gave it to Germany yeah it's to me
threes and fours in that list also
jeremy i don't mean that was equally
equalizers here for a weird conversation
just because i think spelunky was the
game that was the runner-up in our
college like I think that's the game
that we almost could have given game of
the year to spelunking which we probably
should have done I mean let's see I come
article the thing of it journey was when
a journey came out this sort of super
short in the experience alikes like two
to three hour thing Wason thought it's
kind of common there were these more
common especially on consoles this was
kind of like a weird avant-garde thing
you'd see on PC more I feel whereas do
you think perhaps that sort of lend it
to why it wont gave it here because at
the time it was such a novel experience
and I kind of paved the way for more
games like this I think it kind of taps
into that I you know when you're
deciding on Game of the Year what does
Game of the Year mean like is it the
just the best game of this year is it
what uh you know that by rating by
review so it
has to get it is it like the staffs
agreeing is it like enough people's
favorite is it the game that we like
want to keep playing is that the game
that we want more developers to develop
games like we want to see of this more
in the future and so I think it kind of
tapped into that like that like we have
this voice when we are choosing game of
the year on the sort of cultural
zeitgeist of gaming and we want to like
get +1 this game because we like the way
this is going and for as many people as
this comes up in discussions I don't
think anyone would say that journey
wasn't a good game it was a fantastic I
mean it's very you know I love during an
ad one that's really cool it's it's
emotional and without without having to
have any dialogue or any words it's but
i think i also think people like kind of
downplay its mechanics and i actually
think the way it used mechanics is
really special and of course it had that
you know that sort of fluid co-op type
thing yeah that actually sort of started
with demon souls i guess you kind of and
now we're talking that that is actually
true but now you see that everywhere now
in games and i think that's part of
going back to demon souls that's kind of
part of why we chose that and then last
you all that going someone sorry Kevin
and then I'm sorry I'm just bought in in
2012 yeah it's pretty good okay actually
for me far cry 3 but yeah I've read a
poem yeah XCOM was the game we could
agree on okay so back to your what you
were saying earlier yes far cry 3 a
little bit outside of the deliberation
window to like didn't come out and do it
was it was super laser Barrino was the
third we don't create an artificial
deliberation window for our stop we just
kind of say like i have it came out it
came out and we were able to get a hold
of it earlier than regular release so
when you get the Talos principle is a
bit earlier know like when you're
already like three meetings deep in this
game is like quick pick up the phone and
say we're having game of the year debate
send your game over if you want to
consider it if they don't send it over
they're idiots haha fair where the game
is bad at speaking of sort of that I
guess this was a game last year that so
many people have played in so many
people enjoyed that it had to win but
last year the year gta5 came out the
last of us sparsh walk in finish and we
gave it to the legend of zelda a link
between worlds on the nintendo 3ds
our first handheld I guess it was they
are not our first Zelda are also 30
cells the third Zelda but list a
fantastic game on three years last you
remember everyone playing this yeah yeah
it was one of those yeah it really is
great everyone's playing it everyone's
talking about were there everyone's
talking about how these mechanics are
making this world feel fresh and new in
a way that like is Elda hasn't been and
yet it's also still like really playing
on nostalgia in a really smart way like
it you know it it checks every box yeah
you can say a lot of nice things about
some of the other games that came out
that year but this is the game that is
most good most good in terms of just
like you know like you know if you think
about it a lot of the arguments around
game of the year and the deliberations
that we put on giant bomb what we
podcast out are all our deliberations
they're not that different from the
gamespot ones it's just fewer people
yeah get a sense of what the game spots
one gamespot deliberations were in the
past I don't know if you guys still do
it that way but yeah yeah we'd like 25
odd people so yeah you know it is that
kind of like you know wait you end up
saying the worst most negative things
about the second best day that you're
like you just said on charter threes
garble it I actually kind of 22 it do
you know um two at a ten you can't say
that sort of stuff about a link between
worlds yeah and I haven't ring true you
know you like you can you can gin up
some stuff and say well isn't it bad
because it's just basically an old game
and isn't playing on this like no I
don't agree d s so it shouldn't win
right that's that's a good yeah sure
there you go you found the one valid
argument I guess awesome um but yeah
there's nothing wrong that game yeah so
those are all the winners we've had over
the years Jeff thank you so much for
coming on at when a wheel giant bomb's
game of the urban ends we start on the
26 then we go the full week Brad's been
assembling the podcast it is just over
11 hours great of deliberations for our
20 categories Drew's off editing all the
videos and that sort of stuff we've
gotten something like 30 different guest
lists coming in from you know some of
the the people we had last year some new
faces I'm told like I have to go record
audio for one of them
apparently I'm doing voice drops for a
song I don't know what the hell grace
okay it was just there's all kinds of
nonsense so yeah that will go from the
26 to the 30th Alison / thank you very
much and thanks to all three of you for
coming on discussing all the best games
that have we've given on gangster calm
over the past I don't know was a sixteen
seventy years
you